[Música]
como decíamos es el Día Mundial del
medio ambiente y este año está
organizado por costa de marfile con el
enfoque en las soluciones a la
contaminación por plásticos en France 24
nos enfocamos también en este tema y por
eso vemos querido invitar para el
análisis a Jordi Pon él es coordinador
Regional de químicos y de contaminación
del programa de Naciones Unidas para el
medio ambiente Jordi Bienvenido a
directo a América gracias
Hola buenos días cómo están bien Jordi
es un placer saludarlo y quiero empezar
con usted citando la guía práctica
contra el plástico que realiza Naciones
Unidas en conjunto con más
organizaciones y que dice que somos
adictos al plástico no es un producto
que como veíamos hace unos minutos en
salud es barato es flexible es fácil de
transportar es fácil de utilizar Pero
también es un producto que se logra
gracias a los combustibles fósiles al
día de hoy usted considera que existe un
potencial reemplazo o la respuesta está
en el cambio de los modos de consumo
bien no hay una respuesta única una
solución única creo que lo que tenemos
que hacer es intentar combinar todas
aquellas medidas políticas y soluciones
pues que nos permitan
acabar con esta Adicción al plástico y
por supuesto acabar con la contaminación
que actualmente se genera del plástico
por las malas prácticas de gestión de
residuos y por esta Liberación que acaba
llegando tanto a los ecosistemas como a
la salud de las personas Bueno ya que
usted menciona el caso de los
ecosistemas quisiera preguntarle por un
caso grandísimo y conocidísimo que es
estas manchas de contaminación por
plástico que existen en tres de nuestros
océanos y que se acumulan en zonas
flotantes con muchísimos residuos y la
mayoría de estos residuos pues son
plástico la más grande de ellas Casi ya
triplica el tamaño de lo que es Francia
qué iniciativas existen contra este
problema Cómo se podría gestionar este
plástico que ya existe y pues que ya
está causando daño
sí Y es es una contaminación masiva
diríamos que acumulada a lo largo de
muchos años donde hemos estado
invirtiendo cantidades ingentes
toneladas de contaminación plástica de
desechos plásticos en los ríos en los
océanos millones de toneladas cada año
es este diría que es la punta del
iceberg Porque mucha parte de la
contaminación plástica De hecho está en
el interior de los océanos en los
sedimentos en todos los ecosistemas lo
que vemos es la basura flotante que
existen iniciativas para tratar también
de remediarla capturarla captarla pero
lo que tenemos que hacer Efectivamente
es dejar de contaminar dejar de
introducir residuos plásticos en los
ecosistemas por tanto mirar Cuáles son
las soluciones hacia el origen de la
cadena Pero por supuesto también
atendiendo esta contaminación que es
como un legado de nuestras malas
prácticas hasta el día de hoy Bueno y
parte de ese legado los cita la revista
en hechos recology and Evolution
precisamente sobre una de estas grandes
manchas y es la Mancha del océano
Pacífico Allí se ha registrado que
sobreviven una gran diversidad de
organismos principalmente invertebrados
y que en otras condiciones serían
organismos litorales pero que han
logrado a millones de miles de
kilómetros de su hogar natural de
construir si se puede decir unas cierta
suerte de ecosistema ahí hay anémonas
hay esponjas hay otros otros organismos
Cuáles son las consecuencias de estos
falsos ecosistemas que se están creando
bien Estos son como tú como tú mencionas
son ecosistemas artificiales falsos que
si bien pueden estar siendo pues objeto
de El o el hogar de ciertos organismos
están generando más más impactos que
otra cosa no como se mencionaba
anteriormente muchos de estos plásticos
también contienen o tienen adheridos
sustancias químicas aditivos que se
utilizan durante la fase de producción
de los plásticos y también se adhieren
otro tipo de contaminantes por otro
tanto también estos plásticos tienen
efectos muy perniciosos sobre la
macrofauna es decir por estrangulamiento
por ingestión de plásticos hemos visto
ya ese tipo de imágenes Así que En
definitiva es un ecosistema si se puede
mencionar así totalmente artificial y
impactante para los ecosistemas
Cuáles son en su opinión Las mayores
Fuentes contaminantes de la industria
Porque si hacemos una revisión práctica
el plástico hace parte de toda nuestra
vida lo que vestimos donde nos sentamos
donde vivimos los utensilios de la vida
diaria sus gafas es decir todo está
hecho de plástico Cómo podríamos
entonces enfocarnos en ciertas
industrias
como mencionas el plástico está en todas
partes lo utilizamos en nuestra vida
diaria entonces nuestros productos de
consumo en gran medida son tienen mucha
cantidad de plásticos y por tanto lo que
tenemos como que tratar de hacer es Cómo
podemos cambiar ese modelo de producir
utilizar y desechar hacia un modelo que
sea más circular que desde los desde el
origen de la producción de los plásticos
pues ya se diseñan de manera que puedan
ser más reciclables que contengan menos
productos que contengan menos cantidad
de plásticos y que sea más fácil
reciclarlos y esto a lo largo de todos
los sectores productivos de por tanto
que el mercado estas industrias ofrezcan
al consumidor unos productos más
sostenibles y que sean más fáciles de
reciclar nuestro periodista de deportes
mencionaba un ejemplo de de la Gigante
coca-cola los Olímpicos va a poner
dispensadores de vidrio para promover el
reciclaje y la reutilización quería
preguntarle si una iniciativa como esta
o un cambio a modos de consumo como este
es posible soñarlo en algún momento de
la historia porque cada vez que uno
necesita comprar un champú una vez al
mes o una crema un yogurt una vez al día
o a la semana pues está consumiendo un
recipiente nuevo de plástico es posible
cambiar esto ya a un nivel Macro
es más que posible porque de hecho en la
historia que mencionabas ya ha ocurrido
anteriormente muchas personas recordarán
que ya funcionábamos bajo modelos de
retorno no de retorno de envases los
envases eran reutilizables de la leche
de las bebidas etcétera entonces ha sido
la tendencia del mercado que nos ha
llevado y la economía del mercado a esta
a esta situación producir plástico es es
económico es barato pero porque nos
estamos teniendo en cuenta Los costos
ocultos de la contaminación de estos
plásticos Entonces es perfectamente
posible Nosotros hemos calculado en este
informe Que elaboró el programa de las
Naciones Unidas para el medio ambiente
que aplicando las prácticas y las
soluciones las tecnologías que
actualmente disponemos podríamos reducir
en un 80% la contaminación por plásticos
de aquí al 2040 como Pues precisamente
promoviendo estas prácticas de
reutilización de Reyes por ejemplo
rellenar las botellas devolverlas hacer
productos plásticos que sean más más
claves y gestionando adecuadamente
aquellos productos que actualmente pues
no se pueden reciclar y muy importante
hay aquello todos aquellos productos que
son de un solo uso que se desechan
prácticamente de manera instantánea una
vez se consumen todos esos productos que
algunos muchas veces son innecesarios se
pueden reducir al menos en un 30%
respecto a manteniendo pues la
funcionalidad de los mismos o con
materiales alternativos o simplemente
reduciendo la cantidad del sobre empaque
que tenemos actualmente los productos
Muchísimas gracias es Jordi Pon el
coordinador Regional de químicos y
contaminación desde el programa de
Naciones Unidas para el medio ambiente
que tenga un feliz día gracias muchas
gracias Gracias también a nuestros
televidentes quédense con nosotros ya
volvemos con más
[Música]